hello America and the rest of the world
my name is Ryan Wright and olicity crazy
and Randy fries
listen people we're gonna check out a
video from all-time tens called ten
Disney films with shocking origins don't
do no Alisa isn't the Disney oh so much
oh me too yeah yes the other best
friends now it's [ __ ] fantastic we
are hanging out like every day boy
I read I heard I'm here together in her
channel guys check it out it's awesome
Misun we put things in our mouths oh god
top 10 Disney films with disturbing
origins number 10 The Little Mermaid
Disney really is based on the fairy tale
by Danish author Hans Christian Andersen
but in Anderson's original 1837 fairy
tale Little Mermaid doesn't just have to
give up her voice for human legs she has
to have her tongue completely cut out
also being out in the water causes her
excruciating pain in the original story
the handsome prince doesn't marry her
and the heartbroken ex mermaid dissolves
into a luminous spirit as a result of
the spell she's of them look I read
aerial dance to her back her soul by
doing good deeds for 300 years so gladly
happily ever yeah it's terrible below hi
thank you bees Greek classics are
usually full of gruesome depictions and
Hercules is no exception
The Legend of Heracles as he was known
in Greece dates back to the Hellenistic
period 300 years BC in one version of
the legend the muscle-bound sum of Zeus
is made so demented by his stepmother
Hera that he murders his own children he
also has his student if Toph and his set
on fire as he burns he ascends to
Olympus Disney decided to overlook this
scrutinize and had their cartoon
Hercules choose to stay on earth with
his love interest Meg rather than join
the gods Wow like a better option
for them The Hunchback of Notre Dame was
written by Victor Hugo the same author
who wrote him as a table it's therefore
unsurprising that Disney felt the need
to alter the stories somewhat to make
you feel a bit more well Disney in
Hugo's classic Esmeralda is framed for
attempted murder
she's tortured and sentenced to death
Quasimodo manages to rescue her but he
is then betrayed by his adoptive father
Frodo and Esmeralda his hand are looking
Quasimodo murders Frodo and stays with a
lifeless body of his love until he dies
of starvation number seven there's no
white and the seven dwarfs Disney I'm
jamming voice you know nobody close for
the screen very well
an evil queen poisoned apple and a glass
coffin all make for a pretty dark
children's story but Disney obviously
felt that children in 1937 weren't quite
ready for Jacob and Wilhelm Grimm's
original ending in the grim version the
Evil Queen pays for her wicked ways
and is forced to wear a pair of searing
hot iron shoes and dance until she drops
dead number 6 the Fox I come and add his
lovable story of the unlikely friendship
between a dining car burned Fox News 12
has a much more sinister ending in
Daniel P Maddox is 1967 novel in the
Disney adaptation copper defies his
upbringing and puts his own life at risk
to defend his friend but in the book
copper hunts
Tod until the bewildered Fox drops dead
from exhaustion and as if that's not sad
enough coppers owner that shoots his
faithful hound dead
what wow I wonder his new filmmakers
have said that their movie The Lion King
is based on the works of Shakespeare and
fables from the Bible predominantly the
film takes his influence from
Shakespeare's ominously titled
the tragedy of Hamlet Prince of Denmark
in the play Hamlet suspects that his
uncle is responsible for killing his
father the king in order to rule the
kingdom himself both Simba and Hamlet
are visited by the ghosts of their dead
fathers but rather than take strength
and guidance from his ghost Hamlet
arguably descends into mad
the play ends in a bloodbath as his
Hamlet is loved Ophelia her father and
Hamlet's mother and uncle all die which
would have made the Disney movie more
circle of death before Tarzan Disney's
movie Tarzan was adapted from Edgar Rice
Burroughs 1914 novel Tarzan of the Apes
except for one or two pretty crucial
details in the novel Tarzan confesses
his love for Jane who feels the same way
but she is already engaged to Clayton as
the novel progresses
Tarzan also discovers that he is
Clayton's cousin and the rightful heir
to his sizable estate and I know that
yeah rather than fight for the heart of
his true love
Tarzan stays quiet and renounces his own
heritage for the sake of Jane's
perceived happiness
Pocahontas this 90s Disney classic has
been criticized for presenting a
romanticized tale of 17th century
American colonialism the real Pocahontas
was a child when she met the Explorer
Trek 15 a love interest an abyss is
young the smellier Pocahontas saving
Smith's life from NATO captors is
thought to be a myth in reality
Pocahontas was kidnapped and raped and
forced to convert to Christianity and
married off to an Englishman choose then
brought to Britain and paraded around as
a symbol of the taming savage on her
return to America she became violently
ill and died in life but not know any of
that HUS The Ballad of Mulan dates back
to the 6th century I just thought to be
based on a historical female warrior who
live between 386 and 534 seee in the
disney story Mulan becomes a Hamid
warrior and returns home to her
in the 1675 sweet and romance telling of
the story moon that returns from battle
to find out her father has died and her
mother these are so sad worse a local
ruler summons her to become his sex
slave rather than suffer this fate she
commits what the jungle book that have
inspired by Rudyard Kipling's 1894 short
story The Jungle Book film ends with the
abandoned orphan Mowgli returning to
society
however in Kipling's version Mowgli is
not welcome back to civilization instead
he is banished back into the jungle and
the one family that showed him kindness
gets tortured out the storm
movin enlists the help of a bloodthirsty
elephant in a pack of wolves to help him
destroy the entire village in revenge if
you enjoyed this video you found the
interesting go and check our videos by
our friends over 101 facts now wanted
one comes by Disney's panel screen now
I'm going to watch part so 14 days I met
those guys yeah you're cool all-time
movie is another one of the reals and as
always by thank you so much for watching
guys next time okay whoa just sad No The
Little Mermaid one yeah we've talked
about that before
Hercules him choosing to go with the
gods instead of staying on earth yeah I
think that would have been a better
ending whoa really
if it would a man who's not to be a god
if you like I'm gonna stay there for one
woman
his skin yeah yeah come on Veronica
his skin peeled off yeah beautiful
Oh such a [ __ ] he was set on fire and
that's why he chose to go either you
don't
basically like get tortured and arise to
become a god through that and stay on
earth and maybe have a shot at happiness
you'd rather be set on fire in pain to
have your all of your skin fall off and
then become a god a short term though
you guys have these successful people
and think long term gods have way more
power than any man
sure with your woman brains you wouldn't
understand
Oh oh ho ho whatever ladies punch back
an extra dumb okay but look it I just
actually I rewatched this like a week
ago that it's not really yeah and I
didn't realize like I remember watching
it when I was young and thought it was
great
I rewatched it again like I said a week
ago oh my god it's it's so ridiculously
dark however fun fact the author Victor
Hugo two of the gargoyles in the movie
are Victor Hugo yeah okay thanks for the
fun fact
your uncle it's not a fun fact is that
Esmeralda was hung yeah hey yeah yeah
yeah
my fella who he then Rollo is such a
dick yeah way I thought Quasimodo
succeeded in killing for although he did
after after Ezra yeah after shooting
yeah we did and then he started to death
Wayne in my hair it's like a true Romeo
and Juliet story yeah I mean come on
just one woman showed him a little bit
of interest and he was like this ugly
[ __ ] being yeah totally that's just
wrong what's wrong he's seen the Disney
version even in that like he isn't
really not attractive yeah but he has
such a good soul yeah
oh so before you all start becoming
judgmental of what I said how about you
think for a second would you all [ __ ]
Quasimodo he's a cartoon character yeah
no he's okay with the real life
adaptations and all that [ __ ] would you
[ __ ] Quasimodo I didn't I know no you
wouldn't actually no you wouldn't if if
that was real life if his kindness
showed like like if that was that kind
of situation I would give him a chance I
would if Dan look like Quasimodo you
wouldn't be what Dan just saying I'm
talking about just saying
just judging my interest
hardcore um because it makes for
entertaining video yester oh the Fox and
the hound the Fox and the ham is my
favorite Disney movie really ah yeah I'm
really glad they didn't go with the real
ending do you know the endings of all
these sound like here's what the Disney
version did the real ending was exactly
the opposite why did he shoot him why
did he kill his own dog yeah probably
because um you know it's like the dogs
done with his mission animals dumb Zoe's
put the dog yeah baby wasn't dumb in he
was loyal to him I'm not so the animals
don't it is his China I know is he
purposes certain but obviously he's been
loyal to the human by choosing him over
the Fox he was his friend yeah well when
it do you feel like it's time for
someone's life to be done and because
you think their purpose and life is over
you're doing in the favor it's just no
yes
yeah no no I don't know why he's shot I
don't know why he shot copper I'm gonna
have to read that book now and be
depressed and cry for like - yeah I mean
the fact that copper killed Todd is just
see I like the switch in Fox and the
hound
not because it's like oh they Disney
fied the ending it's because it makes
for a really powerful moment when copper
stands in front of the shotgun you know
protecting Todd that was a powerful
moment so I am ok with that change you
know we're the best of friends
oh yeah and the Tarzan one another doing
another Tarzan movie right now
yeah yeah live-action woman yeah I hope
it follows that real one yeah yeah well
cuz it's it's gonna be a lot of CGI a
lot of green screen and stuff like that
well the fact that Tarzan decides to you
know let Jane go ah that's a real man
right oh my heartstrings that's us huh
but it makes sense what she's gonna just
a jungle life come on yes way more
privileges out in America
and living the trust for my versus
versus less social pressure but it's
like live with Avenel x' and have fun
aminals yeah you think you just chill
with the animals
Emin old what if Tarzan has an ape
friend who's really into him and then
Jane comes along and then the Apes like
[ __ ] you Jane and then pounds on Jane
kills Jane
Tarzan's devastated out no and then he's
like I wish I just let her go back to
her hometown that would never happen
yeah I don't think either the Pocahontas
wouldn't shock me really I was always
told that's not how it went down
really but I didn't know she was
kidnapped and raped and then forced to
be this like you know horrible symbol of
like savages that's yeah that is [ __ ]
up with Disney tape yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] up that is like totally twisting
history it's not like that's what people
and movies do all the time anyway memory
do great watching going back there's no
like oh yeah that's what we learned
okay with the same no but sane and
glorious bad yeah that's totally
different though because that doesn't
that claims to be a piece of historical
fiction this on the other hand your kids
in the animated movie it's an animated
movie but so many people are learning
the story of Pocahontas through this and
they think this is how it kind of went
down like maybe there wasn't talking to
animals and [ __ ] or trees yeah but he's
like you think like oh they fell in love
and things worked out yeah no that
didn't work out in the movie he went
home have you seen the second one the
second one the second Pocahontas just
makes me mad that one I got only not
raped and tortured she goes to London
he's trying to like get back to her be
like I still love you could stall this
stuff and she meets this other guy
basically she just goes yeah I still
love you but [ __ ] you yeah yeah Sean's
be mad John Rolfe yeah oh yeah yeah
played by Christian Bale in a new world
but Milan was also based off a real life
yeah yeah well Mulan I could be a little
bit more forgiving on because that's the
ending after she did the awesome thing
she did yeah along with that apparently
from from what I've heard the real Mulan
actually she was found out but continued
to be I think she was a captain or
general for like ten years or something
of course she can't act yeah before she
came back she didn't commit suicide she
didn't want to be a sex slave
good call move on yeah I'm man so sad
that's really she could just kill the
guy the problem for multiple guys to be
very common yeah right I she killed
herself and not killed him
those kids are wondering why Tim but
then of course the last one were Mowgli
gets some serious [ __ ] revenge in the
new jungle but that's how I feature it
I'll be upset I didn't want Mowgli to be
that's that's a cooler ending to me it's
me sure if I'm Disney ending but it's a
cooler in it and it makes more sense yes
yeah but at the same time like you I
feel like I would leave the theater
being like I just I wouldn't have a good
feeling in my in my gut no but it would
be if we wanted to do stuff is stick
with you for a couple days but it
doesn't mean it wouldn't be now I would
love to see a movie both enough to take
that ending because that that's pretty
sweet that ending yeah I like the time
I'd like to take that ending we feel a
MOLLE you know what no that's a little
kid no make that simple day necessity
you forget about you berries in your sky
life okay just imagine like an epic
scene where Mowgli is like writing and
with all the animals and just killing
everyone a pack of wolves I think okay I
think that would be something cool to
add into the film however I don't think
that's how they should end it if they
die you take that they should keep going
and have they should have like one
survivor but there needs to be like I
can't be an ending yeah you know we
could and it is [ __ ] a book but it
shouldn't be the UH and nothing I mean
not like a badass just like [ __ ] you
guys for her because all these other
endings it's like the main character is
now dead there's something
the main character now suffers a
horrible life you know it's it's like
Nitra little refreshing to be like least
Mowgli's like getting some revenge or
all the horrible you know who would do
it Quentin Tarantino yeah would you do
it would do it yeah I'm gonna do it well
you know it's dialogue it was like it
was cool
it'd be cool really cool yeah anyway
guys thank you all time tens for
presenting that video is very kind of
you and I respect you sexually if you're
new to the channel you should subscribe
to the real rejects by clicking this
button in the center of me right here
ELISA be crazy
ELISA be crazy has a channel she blogs
and [ __ ] and does challenges yeah every
Tuesday tipsytuesday just gonna drunk
she just did a video with Brenda price
yeah that's a channel with reactions and
reviews and monologues and movie reviews
and well do better
mm-hmm-hmm you just don't know a lot of
boys what yeah by exposing your tongue
you have now turned on a lot of boys but
that's just weird
that is how a guy's mind works he's a
little bit of a tongue and now he's like
wouldn't know all the tongue is what if
it girls tongue is only like this one
well at least a lot to the imagination
just kind of funny is over